the modern world is wonderful in many
ways dentistry is good cars are reliable
we can so easily keep in touch from
Mexico with our grandmother in Scotland
but it's also powerfully and tragically
geared to causing a high background
level of anxiety and widespread
low-level depression there are six
particular features of modernity that
have this psychologically disturbing
effect each one has a potential cure
which we will only collectively put into
action when we know more about the
disease in question here are the six one
meritocracy in our societies tell us
that everyone is free to make it if they
have the talent and energy the downside
of this ostensibly liberating and
beautiful idea is that any perceived
lack of success is taken to be not as in
the past an accident or misfortune but
as a sure sign of a lack of talent or
laziness if those are the top deserve
all their success then those at the
bottom must surely deserve all their
failure a society that thinks of itself
as meritocratic turns poverty from a
problem to evidence of damnation and
those who have failed from unfortunates
to losers the Cure is a strong
culturally endorsed belief in two big
ideas Luck which says success doesn't
just depend on talent and effort and
tragedy which says good decent people
can fail and deserve compassion rather
than contempt - individualism an
individualistic society preaches that
the individual and their achievements
are everything and that everyone is
capable of a special destiny it's not
the community that matters the group is
for no hopeless to be ordinary is
regarded as a curse the result is that
the very thing that most of us will end
up being statistically speaking is
associated with Frank
failure the cure is a cult of the good
ordinary life and proper appreciation of
the pleasures and quiet heroism of the
everyday 3 secularism secular societies
cease to believe in anything that is
bigger than or beyond themselves
religions used to perform the useful
service of keeping our petty ways and
status battles in perspective but now
there is nothing to all or relativize
humans whose triumphs and mishaps end up
feeling like the be-all and end-all a
cure would involve regularly using
sources of transcendence to generate a
benign relativizing perspective on our
personal sorrows music the stars at
night the vast spaces of the desert or
the ocean would humble us all in
consoling ways for romanticism the
philosophy of Romanticism tells us that
each of us has one very special person
out there who can make us completely
happy yet mostly we have to settle for
moderately bearable relationships with
someone who is very nice in a few ways
and pretty difficult in many others it
feels like a disaster in comparison with
our original huge hopes the cure is to
realize that we didn't go wrong we were
just encouraged to believe in a very
improbable dream instead we should build
up our ambitions around friendship and
sexual love five of the media the media
has immense prestige and a huge place in
our lives but it routinely directs our
attention to things that scare worry
panic and enrage us while denying us
agency or any chance for effective
personal action
it typically attends to the least
admirable sight of human nature without
a balancing exposure to normal good
intentions responsibility and decency at
its worst it edges us towards mob
justice the Cure would be news that
focused on presenting solutions rather
than generating outrage that was alive
to systemic problems rather than
gleefully emphasizing scapegoats or
emblematic monsters and that would
regularly remind us that the news we
most need comes from our own lives and
direct experiences six perfectibility
modern societies stress that it is
within our remit to be profoundly
content sane and accomplished as a
result we end up leveling ourselves
feeling weak and sensing that we've
wasted our lives a cure would be a
culture that endlessly promotes the idea
that perfection is not within our grasp
that being mentally slightly and
appoints very unwell is an inescapable
part of the human condition and that
what we need above all our good friends
with whom we can sit and honestly
discuss our real fears and
vulnerabilities the forces of
psychological distress in our world are
currently much wealthier and more active
than the needed cures we deserve tender
pity for the price we have to pay for
being born in modern times but more
hopefully cures are now open to us
individually and collectively if only we
recognized with sufficient clarity the
sources of our true anxieties and
sorrows
[Music]
did you know the school of life is a
real place with classes events and a
shop visit our website to learn more
you